what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today
i'm going to be addressing a hate
comment
or a common complaint that i get fairly
often on the channel now before i start
don't forget to subscribe to the channel
and bring that notification bell also
sign up for my memberships i do some
behind the scenes vlogs
and
i forgot what else oh and you get to be
a part of our live chat i had to like
think about what do we all
sorry our vlogs are lit though i'm gonna
be doing one where i'm like rapping
and if you guys can't believe it
you'll have to sign up for a membership
it'll probably come out in a week or two
anyways
so a common complaint i get on the
channel is that i'm a grifter
now first and foremost i actually didn't
know what a grifter meant
so again it's like people insult me and
i'm like i don't know a lot of words
i'm like
i i don't know so i googled it it said a
grifter might be a pickpocket a crooked
grant gambler a scammer or a confidence
man
grift
may come from a graft a slightly
older word to mean acquire dishonesty
so first the first reason i was confused
is because i was like
i don't sell anything
i don't sell anything i guess i do sell
merch but guys i swear to god i think
i've maybe sold 10 sweatshirts i
you could be the 11th you could be the
11th
actu i don't even know if i've sold that
many so
second of all
so then i was like okay what's an
example of grifting you know
because you know i just want to examine
the case i was like am i a grifter you
know i'm gonna play devil's advocate
here maybe i am
a grifter is a con artist someone who
swindles uh people out of money through
fraud
if you're if there is one type of person
you don't want to trust it's a grifter
someone who cheats others out of their
money which i was confused again
i don't sell anything
i guess the memberships but i'm like i'm
selling a behind-the-scenes vlog
anyways so
the other common complaint i get is like
why is she doing this
and
i have a couple reasons why i'm doing
this
more than one so
first of all since i've been a kid i
have been like the nosiest [ __ ] alive
i am the type that just researches
things just to their end and i've always
been the type to like research things to
through youtube or
i i do audio books more than i read but
i do read
sometimes
more audiobooks but
so for example a couple years ago i was
trying to decide what religion i was and
i literally like made a pros and cons
lists of all the religions and i
couldn't figure out why like none of
them stuck with me and that like
something felt off about each one and
then rollo tomasi ruined church for me
so go check out his video and how we
were in church um
that's that's a whole different day so
part of like the red pill was honestly
when i first got into this i was just
nosy i was like i to know what the men
are talking about
and
then i like started to learn more and
more and you guys could go through my
red pill evolution like
there's some stuff i definitely like
switched my opinion on when i was
presented new evidence so i was like
maybe people think i just switch it up
but it's just more like
if you watch new content
yeah i mean and you you're presented
with better facts you change your
opinion that's
um for example i don't think women
should vote
i genuinely i i've been thinking about
this long and hard and let me know if
you could think of a counter-argument
but i've been thinking i'm like do women
really deserve to vote
and the more i do this show the more i
think no
the more i think no there's an example
okay
i'm trying to think of what else so
though and then oh right so then i'm
watching the content and the thing is
the more i watched it the more i
identified like with i have brothers uh
my five brothers to be exact um i also
have four sisters people think i just
grew up with boys and i we
mix and um some of my brothers had some
like
issues and
the more i watched the content the more
i was like wow like if that was my
brother
um
you know life is actually really hard
for men and i don't know i just was
i i don't know like i have empathy you
know
and i know they say women can't truly
empathize with men
so maybe maybe it wasn't empathy i don't
know but i just i don't know i resonated
with my brother and my dad like i look
up to my dad more than anyone else in
the world so
so i was like is that why they think i'm
a grifter i mean people will talk no
matter what i'm just i'm just examining
the claim and then i'm like okay guys
you realize a pickpocket a crooked gamer
a scammer
i'm like if you
i'm not selling anything one and two i
was like
you realize i worked in sales for two
years i hated that job
but i could be good at a lot of stuff
like i want to do music after this
i'm gonna recent release an album next
year i will release an album
and um
i also i also did tic tac before this
guys i had an 80 female audience on tik
tok and it's slowly getting less and
less and less and
like i could have went honestly i
probably would have made more money
going the tick tock route and just like
selling to females and like doing like a
american in london i'm just i was more
interested in the red pill stuff
like because i've just always been nosy
so before i even got into red pill and
jordan peterson kind of is red pill but
not
not really so
jordan peterson like thomas sowell
all of those guys i already listened to
so when i listened to like rolo tomasi
who i think is like the most talented
guy in the
like mo like he knows his [ __ ] the most
you know in the red pill
i was like it was just like a natural
evolution for me so that's kind of what
i bring women through on my show i'm
like
first you debate them tell them a couple
ideas you're like oh
then you bring them back you show them
other people's content they're like oh
and then
i might hire you
usually not though i'm like full on
spots now
but yeah that's um
that's me addressing the claim am i a
grifter i'm trying to think of other
insults people call me but let me know
in the comments if you have any
questions um let me know if you think
i'm a grifter or not you can you know go
either way i don't really care
um don't forget to subscribe to the
channel ring that notification bell and
i'll talk to you next time